Erica Wernick: Everything that
we say we want is because of
how we think we're going to feel when we get it...
Film Courage: How do you define success?
Erica: My definition of success has changed
over the last two years and I would not
be surprised if it changed again in
the next coming years. I think that
for the last 10 years I really define success
by the projects I was booking and the money I
was making and once I got those things that
I desired then I realized wait a minute
I really just want to be happy (not that some
of those things didn't make me happy) but
now I'm really chasing for lack of a
better word what makes me happy and
and that's to me more important i think that i'm
still weaving into my you know one of my coaches
was like oh so you say that's what or maybe my
therapist said this you say that success is just
about what makes you happy but you're still
kind of living in this world where you want
to make a certain amount of money and you want
to book certain projects and and so i think that
i have one foot in that world and one foot in
this world but for me it's so much more about
being happy and helping people
and so i'm i'm trying to
refocus my energy on that because i think it's
really easy to get caught up especially in the
social media world where we're comparing ourselves
to other people all the time and what their lives
look like and where they're spending their money
and what projects you know i think um you know
a lot of my actor clients we talk about how their
least favorite question ever is have i seen you in
anything or are you working on anything now people
feel very insecure about that question and so
i just you know i myself have gotten very
caught up in what projects i'm working on
so that i can tell other people and then i
will be perceived as successful and being
perceived as successful is more important than
how i actually feel doing these things and so
um so now i'm just trying to let go of that and
focus on what makes me happy like i think that
you know it's like if we look back at
our lives i don't know i would rather be
happy and doing things that feel good
and excite me than constantly worrying
about trying to compare myself to others
and what it looks like to other people
what do you think about the fact that that's
a great place to be in but some people might
need to have kissed the ring so to speak and then
realize you know what it wasn't that great and i
actually just want to be happy but they needed
that experience to know i actually was up here
for a little bit and i decided i wasn't happy but
i needed to know what that felt like yeah i think
that we all are on our own journey we all are on
our own path you know if i had to experience that
to learn this lesson it's not even necessarily
a lesson it's just a redirect for myself
um and so i don't think there's anything wrong
with like some people just have to live out
their journey and live out their own experiences
than to decide what they want you know i think
that's what we're always collecting data based
on how we feel so everything that we do we're
collecting data and then we're re-evaluating
so i think that's totally okay but what i do
sort of direct people in my book is to and
again this is something that i feel like
that i've been working on is to stop setting
goals that are based on validation right so
try to at least start chasing the joy because i
think that the all those things that you think
you want they're going to come anyway right you
can be happy and get all those things but we don't
necessarily always know why we want those things
and so i think it is important to take a look at
like well why do i want that you know like i
remember i have a dream of buying a house it
used to be in the hills but now i want one in the
palisades or you know with ocean view as opposed
to city view and i remember someone said to me
oh do you want that because of how it'll look
and i said oh my gosh no that that's not part of
this dream for me at all i want it because i have
family back on the east coast and i want rooms
for them to come visit for extended periods of
time so that i can be you know i'm very close
with my family and i hate that they're so far
away and i don't get to see them very often um and
i'm also very sensitive to my surroundings that i
want surroundings that inspire me and excite
me and so it's really what it's about and so
i think yeah i think if you're feeling like well
i want the money or i want the accolades it's just
about getting really honest with yourself about
why you want those things everything that we say
we want is because of how we think we're going to
feel when we get it so if you you know if you want
an oscar why why do what do you think you're going
to feel when you get that oscar and and i think
that if you can break down those feelings it's
more important to sort of chase those feelings
or to try to feel those now than necessarily the
the label that you think is going to give you
those feelings um if that makes sense so i think
you know like i said in my book it's really about
like set any goal that you want there's nothing
wrong with any of them um but if you're chasing
them for validation to make you feel good to
make you feel more worthy or more deserved
deserved deserve it um it probably isn't going
to feel the way that you think it's going to
feel it's not going to solve the inner problem
right like none of the external things that we
create for ourselves or that we get aren't going
to are never going to solve an internal problem
i think most of this is is validation from
others or self-validation validation from others
you think that matters more to most
people i think a lot i think a lot of us
make decisions based on how others
will perceive it how like for example
everyone and their mother in this industry says
that they want to work on netflix you know on a
netflix project and you know there might be some
like there might be some reasons behind that
in the terms of well they do great work you know
they they tell complex stories and i'm interested
in the stories that they're telling but a lot of
people especially the actors that i work with or
the directors the writers they say they want
netflix because netflix is a huge well-known
entity right now and if they book something
netflix they can then post it on social media
or they can tell people hey i booked a netflix
show and that makes them feel successful because
they're perceived as successful because it's
a network or streamer that everybody knows
right but what if what was really important
to you that you booked a project that told a
meaningful story that impacted people's lives and
that was really fun to create and it felt really
great like you were working with great people
collaborating with great people and the whole
experience just felt good well what if you could
get that experience at abc or on hulu or you know
or another smaller now you know because i talk
about one of my best experiences in hollywood
was a show that was on abc family which is now
free form you know and i don't think many people
are like i want to work on freeform like
everyone's like i want to work on netflix you know
it's not maybe as sexy maybe they don't have quite
as many viewers but it was the most fun i ever
had on a show and we were telling a meaningful
story and there were really amazing crew and cast
members it was just a really good experience so
yeah i think that it's this is a long way to say
i i think it is about chasing validation from
others and how we are perceived by others
and does that go back to sort of that
boxes thing that you said like being in la
you you think that there's these certain rules
in these boxes and it's the same thing about like
oh oh you're just doing the um the score network
i've never heard of it yeah oh okay yeah no but
if you were somewhere else oh wow you're on a tv
show how cool right but here there's these levels
right the hierarchy yeah yeah i i don't know
if it's necessary i guess the box is in a way
where you're like boxing yourself into what your
dream has to look like like my dream has to look
like me working for netflix um so i guess in a
way but i do think yeah that people don't realize
that it's probably going to be a more enjoyable
experience if you intentionally try to create
a good experience for yourself you know like
a show that you love working on that you're
doing meaningful work then whatever
the label of the network or the studio
is you know because you know look like i've
i've known series regulars who have quit
and who just like after a few seasons weren't
feeling fulfilled anymore it wasn't like a story
they felt like was meaningful in their lives
you know and so that happens you know like you
might get the thing that you think you want like
you might get netflix and then it not be a good
experience i'm not trying to put that out there
i'm sure like there's a lot of amazing experiences
on netflix but my point is like get clear about
how you want the experience to feel and what you
want the experience to look like like i say in
my book like write make a list of everything
that you want in the next project you want to
book or whatever goal you're working towards
write the list of everything that everything you
think netflix is going to give you right write
down everything you think it's going to give you
and then take away netflix at the top and then but
still but still chase your list right so you're
still really going after what you truly want
but you're allowing it to look however it looks
how do you help people with the part of success
where they want what other people have i mean that
is happening all the time and i have found myself
getting caught up in that
too you know i think that
when people post things on social media i think
that's like really a lot of where it comes from
as opposed to seeing it in actual real
life i think that when we see somebody's
highlight reel on social media
we are putting a whole story behind that post
about what it means and how it must feel
for them to have what that thing right so
if somebody posts a picture of themselves
driving a porsche you know a fan's very fancy car
and they're smiling in it and they're like yeah
you know they look cool you might then create
this whole story about what that means for that
person and how their life must be so amazing and
it must feel so good for them and wow they have
so much money and we create this whole narrative
about what it means when we see them having this
thing and we're like well we want those feelings
i i want to feel financially stable i want to
feel wealthy i want to um feel excited about a
new purchase i want to have a car like that right
so we we think that they're feeling a certain way
when they have something and then we want to feel
that way and so we think the way we feel it is to
try to get the same thing they have and it's
so easy to get caught up in whatever we think
you know people are or whatever we're seeing
people have you know even if it's a a booking
you know if you book a job or you have an
audition or something you know i think that
if you see someone post online that um i'm
trying to think of something that maybe i've
thought i wanted but i didn't actually want
like like for example one of my clients
said you know what they're an actor
and they were like you know what
every actor wants to be series regular they think
it's like hitting the lottery you know financial
lottery because it's it's a lot of money and
it's consistent work and one of my clients was
like you know what i don't think i want to be
serious regular at this time in my life like
because you usually have to wake up at like four
in the morning you know you're there all day it's
a very long day you have to wake she's like i
don't know if i really i kind of like waking up
at eight o'clock and said you know i don't know if
that's really what i want in my life right now so
she had to you know get honest about wait a minute
what makes me happy what would make me happy now
so i think social media plays a big role in
it but but it's really what we decide it means
right what we decide it means that this person
booked this project or has this opportunity
we also don't know the truth about what it means
to that person or what they're really feeling
on the other side of it you know maybe they're
like posting i i had this amazing audition for
this for netflix wow i'm so lucky i have such
a great life but really they're feeling like
maybe it was like a two-line role and it was
something that they're not actually excited about
but they're trying to tell the world that they had
this netflix audition and then people that see it
are like oh man they have this great life they're
getting these netflix auditions and then we create
the story about what we think they're feeling
or what you know so i think it comes down to
what are the feelings you want to
feel when you get the thing you want
and stop assuming that every single
person who has something feels that
exact way because i think we're attaching
those feelings to what other people have
you